and now pink has an important new gig
that has nothing to do with singing we
talked to her about that but also the
job that's closest to her heart and
that's raising her four-year-old little
girl
Willow is all me she's cute like her
papa and she's mean like her mama with
the holidays around the corner the pop
rebel says her daughter wants some face
time with Santa willow
would like to meet Santa and she wants
Santa to just understand what she needs
which sounds like me with their dad
actually it's perfect racer Carey Hart
Pink's next move is helping kids meet
their needs all over the world as
UNICEF's new ambassador they're working
to help children all over the world and
this especially is amazing because one
in four kids in America are inactive and
one in four kids globally are
malnourished they have brilliantly I
think figured out a way to link the two
and to empower kids in this country
she's following in the footsteps of
Sarah Jessica Parker and Audrey Hepburn
helping to fight malnutrition by
launching their kid power campaign by
purchasing a UNICEF kid power band kids
get active and earn points the points
unlock therapeutic food packets that
deliver life-saving nutrition to
children in need I love kids I think
it's the adults that screw everything up